i understand that but you're
um my sidekick and the engineer got it
and don't out to
me next time okay okay so do the
countdown i'm ready all right here we go
five four no no no no no
less is more lessons more lessons would
just be you
welcome ah welcome to another episode of
tiger belly i am your captain the slept
king
um your emperor you mean the one that
you follow
i lead you follow and vice versa we've
got some beautiful people in the room
um what an episode is this george 180
180 80. okay welcome
um this is a very exciting episode for
me because um we have a guest that i've
been wanting on this podcast for years
have we not talked about this
guest years ago we're like give me a
list i threw it and then we're like i
don't there's no way i'm gonna be able
to get a hold of this guy
he's too rock starry but um we have them
but my point is let's start with uh
introducing everyone to uh the the group
the people that are on the boat uh we
have a crew we have a crew here we have
the guy that
runs the engines in the boat you know
what i mean he does all the
the levers i don't know how boats work
coal yeah yeah
to get revving right we got that guy
right we have this uh
the guy that helps with the side boats
you know how there's side boats on the
boat life rafts
yeah i call them side boats yeah yeah so
we got side boat guy
right we have the co-captain here right
she does the navigating ah
yeah like magellan go north that's what
do that she does
and we got this guy this guy is um um
you're the
you work at the restaurant oh great on
the boat yeah yeah you serve
the help yeah i don't even have a name
okay
like the captain wouldn't know your name
he would go hey kid
get me a cappuccino that's you
now go this is the boat we don't have
that we don't have cappuccino it's
it's a luxury liner oh okay
um and so years ago
i'm gonna i'm gonna introduce you years
ago um i was on a
television program that only nine
mexicans watched
it was called um mad tv um
raoul thank you for watching pedro
there's three pedros thank you for
watching
um and during my math tv days we i did
his um i think in a radio show that i
did i met
him but i was a big fan before um he had
a show called love line
he had a big radio show um he's everyone
knows who he is
um and here's what i'm i'm really into
manifestation
i really am i'm in the manifestation and
um
we were talking about who we wanted and
i manifest in my mind like
how am i going to get him and the comedy
store had a festival
it was called what was called comedy for
festival
unique name yeah it's very unique name
yeah they called it with big fonts
right with the and i was at this
festival and it was me
who was on it a bunch of people david
spade
you know and i was first and then they
go dr drew
is here he's doing a little side
broadcast i go what the [ __ ] i manifest
the [ __ ]
and i did his thing and i looked at him
dr drew pinsky and i said i said
i said can you do my podcast he said yes
so i did his
you know a month ago i don't know if you
know that crew man what's your name
i don't have a name yeah that's exactly
cappuccino coming up
exactly why you're [ __ ] here bro yep
all right to have no name um
and i want a really deep round of
applause
to our guests dr dupinski everybody clap
your hands doctor
they can speak now yeah you can speak
now i've told do not speak till spoken
to
yeah yeah i had a couple things to say
yeah go ahead first of all am i being
punked is that what's happening no no no
no no no no this is
the way we do it secondly secondly um i
don't know what was happening that day
all of a sudden i
opened my eyes and i was at the comedy
festival i i know what happened somebody
manifested me and i just appeared
and the secret bro the manifesting was
just
my voice i got a little cold but the
manifesting was just one part the other
part was how hard you had to fight to
get me in your podcast
i believe you said would you come in
your podcast
right so i manifested you there and i
just showed up there it's weird and you
said that you had a cold
now i have a cold now yeah as well you
manifested it
no i didn't manifest that i didn't i
called in you